okay let's start
um welcome to the ddps seminar uh
today before we introduce today's
speaker
let's go over some rules and logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless it is urgent
so that our speaker can talk without
unnecessary interruptions
that way we all can enjoy and focus on
the talk
second no classified discussion
is allowed here so watch out
finally the talk today will be recorded
so if you have questions it is
encouraged
to use the chat room so that our speaker
can address
them at the end of the seminar but if
you like to address the question right
away
you cannot mute yourself and ask
questions that's no problem
okay that's about it now let's introduce
our speaker today
um i'm honored to host
today's speaker professor stephen
brunton from university of washington
strictly speaking i do not have to
introduce him because he
is just famous you probably all know him
as a great scientist and popular
youtuber
if you are not aware of his youtube
channel
try to search his name in youtube you
will
see a series of lectures very informal
on various computational science
subjects such as food fluid mechanics
machine learning and many more he has
achieved a great deal
in his career just to mention a few he
received the
army and air force young investigator
program awards
and the presidential early career awards
for scientists
and engineers today he is going to talk
about interpretable
and generalizable machine learning for
fluid mechanics
we expect a great talk from steve today
now
let me pass the button to steve see it's
all yours
so thank you very much for the very kind
introduction and also for the invitation
and thank you all for being here so it's
really a pleasure to get to tell you
uh just a little kind of window into
what's happening in my lab
and in the labs of some of my close
collaborators working on this very
interesting problem of machine learning
for fluid dynamics uh and before i jump
in i want to
acknowledge some of my closest
colleagues and co-authors on the work
i'm going to show today
a lot of what i'm going to talk about
has been work done with nathan kutz
and john priasoph lazo and many of our
excellent
phd students and postdocs imaged below
here
and i'll point out this is really just
kind of zoom into one topic in my lab
and so kind of in the picture
you'll feel free to interrupt and ask
any questions you want
or you know a lot i'm going to talk that
i'm not
going to talk about is on youtube or in
our papers
so a lot of what i'm going to talk about
today is going to parallel
a review paper that we recently wrote
and i saw it with barrett noak and
petros kubitzakis
and this was an annual review of food
mechanics in machine learning for fluid
mechanics
and so the big idea here is
that machine learning is not going to
replace
modeling immunizations experiments
is going to complement our historical
efforts in these thrusts
and so um just like the computational
fluid
and the abs did not
put us out of business but instead
created this complementary view of the
world
we believe that that's how machine
learning is also going to enter
uh in this next phase of data intensive
studies
and so um you know i like giving the
talk to an audience here like a
technical audience
of scientist engineers but i often find
myself giving this talk
to senior leaders at companies like
boeing or lockheed
and often when i talk about machine
learning i get this feeling
that maybe they think of machine
learning as a magic wand
they've got some big engineering problem
that's costing them billions of dollars
and they're gonna point magic the magic
wand at it and proof
it's going to get better and that's not
how machine learning works
so at the very offset i want to give you
an idea
of how i think of machine learning as it
relates to engineering problems
so i want to massively oversimplify
and say that machine learning is a
growing set
of techniques to build models from data
either through optimization or
regression
okay so it's a better way of modeling
from an
increasingly rich set of data through
advanced optimization and regression
algorithms developed over the past
decades in statistics
and so in blue here i'm pointing out
hopefully
they have our chronicle
mechanics small russian sparse sensing
optimal sensor placement
optimal control these can naturally be
posed as optimization problems
and those optimization problems have the
challenges outlined in pink
they are non-linear because the navy or
stokes equations are not linear
they're high dimensional because our
fluids are often multi-scale
in space and time so we need lots of
discretization points
and that culminates into a very large
non-convex optimization problem
lots of local minima to solve these
optimal control
and sensing and modeling problems in
fluids
and that's why they've been
traditionally so challenging
learning is a growing set of techniques
that is tailored specifically for these
kinds of high
non-context optimization problems that
occur
in image classification and video
processing
and so there's a lot that we can carry
with us over to our engineering problems
in fluid mechanics
now this is a just snapshot of how i see
the world i want to give you a big
picture of what my
lab does i like to joke that i'm a bit
of a control freak so i try to put
everything in the world up here in the
dynamics block
and then i spend my time in my lab
trying to
focus on how to design controllers to
manipulate the behavior of my system
to some engineering nominal
configuration
and so a lot of what my lab works on is
applying machine learning to those
dynamical system
models of these complex systems and we
want them to be interpretable and
generalizable we want to uncover the
underlying
physics of the systems as much as
possible
good and i'll talk a lot more about this
block
in a little bit the next area we focus a
lot on
is in trying to learn controllers
through trial and error through kind of
biologically inspired
optimization algorithms and a lot of our
work is in renewable energy systems
aerospace fluid systems and then the
third
big area of work that we think about a
lot in my lab
is in sparse sensor placement and
optimization
so if you had a set of sensors a few
sensors or actuators where would you put
them to maximally impact your system
and this is very much inspired by
biological
uh systems like pets that
have on their wings distributed tens if
a strain sensitive neuron
that they use to reform their control
algorithms
now i want to point out at the offset
that although i'm going to be talking
about fluid dynamic systems
most of what i'm talking about will
apply to generic high dimensional
your multi-scale analysis so you can
think about a disease spreading across a
continent
or your network of neurons in your brain
or a financial market
these are kind of high dimensional time
varying nonlinear processes
that we can uncover models and
controllers
and get good sensor and actuator
placement because i'm going to discuss
today good now
i'm going to start off my kind of
vignettes into machine learning for
fluids with what i'm going to call
kind of the lowest hanging fruit and
lowest hanging fruit in
machine learning for fluids is when you
can treat your data like it's an image
or a series of images that are evolving
in time
because there have been literally
billions of dollars of industry
investment over the last few decades
on developing uh very powerful image
processing techniques in robot
statistics and machine learning
um so the the minute we can cast our
problem as an
image science problem we get tremendous
amounts
of algorithms for free and so i love
this picture this is taken from a review
paper by sam tyra from ucla
where he's pointing out kind of this
emergence
of low dimensional coherent structures
or
patterns in this very complex flow over
richiri island
low passive mountain that's the volcano
uh and you can see that even though it's
a very complex geophysical flow
it has this emergency street
that we see in much simpler low reynolds
number of blow pass facility the idea
that they're
separating low dimensional patterns that
emerge in these fluid dynamics
applications
is one of the cornerstones of modern
fluid
but it's also a cornerstone of machine
learning all of what we talk about
in machine learning is based on the fact
that there are pattern data
that you can exploit for some objective
and there were patterns we'd be sub
there would be no effort or no point in
putting in the effort to machine
learning
or to data-driven
so the first thing i want to show you is
this one by isabel cheryl who's
the phd student working with brian
pelagi
and what she's done here is trying to
take these
image processing and techniques from
image sciences
and apply their emotional fluid
mechanics
so here in the movie pivot path system
to make
it much more like when you get the
experiments from a particle image
velocimetry laser sheet experiment
and any of you who have done these
experiments know that
you don't get perfectly clean flow
fields you often have this kind of tv
static
that's on top of the flow field and
we've made it extra bad here as a
cartoon
but the goal in this case is to leverage
the fact that there are patterns
to clean the data and extract those
patterns and clean up the
noise and so what we're trying to do
is take this movie given by x and
decompose it into the sum of two movies
l plus s where l has all of the coherent
structures
and statistically correlated patterns
and s is everything that's
really uncorrelated with that low
dimensional structure
and this move cartoon this is really
an algorithm that she wrote for this
data in x and this is the decomposition
she gets
which is an incredible clean version of
l the actual flow past the cylinder
that separates out all of the
contaminates
so again to do this it really relies on
writing down the right optimization
problem
in this case this seems too good to be
many ways of decomposing one matrix into
the sum of two
and so we find the right decomposition
we want by imposing our physical priors
into the optimization problem
in this case we want l to be low rank
and we want s to be sparse
and this is the famous robust principle
components analysis algorithm of candes
at all
that we have uh extended and used for
fluid systems
now the optimization i have in blue is
non-convex
and intractable at scale this does not
scale with moore's law
so we have to relax this to something
that does scale
and so the convex relaxation we swap out
the rank of l for the nuclear norm
and we swap out the zero norm of s for
the one norm
and those with high probability will
still promote these low rank sparse
decompositions
now when you take the clean version in l
and compute the principal components we
get the modes on the right column
that are almost perfect in almost
perfect agreement with the true modes of
the clean system
and if we naively apply this dimension
to the
noisy data and x we would get these
contaminated modes in the middle
now when you build models based on these
models sorry based on these modes
so dmd before that
you get a bunch of values inside the
unit circle
we accept all the eigenvalues to live on
the unit circle because it's
a purely periodic system but many of
them are contaminated with that noise
however after applying the most clean
procedure and we applied dmv to the
l matrix almost all of our eigenvalues
are perfectly on the unit circle
so this is really good confirmation that
this is working not just for getting
modes but for getting models
in this i'll point you to isabelle's
paper
in physical review fluids where she
applies this to the johns hopkins
turbulence database the
uh turbulent channel flow see what
happens
r on high wave number of turbulence when
we apply this decomposition
so really interesting results she also
applies this to two experimental piv
datasets
good long story short if you can view
your
flow field as an image sheet you
immediately
get techniques for free so another
example that's really promising is super
resolution
so this is very very closely related to
many problems in fluid mechanics where
either you have limited measurements of
assist
or where you want to simulate a high
resolution system with low resolution
grid
like in a large eddy simulation
and so this is worked by ben erickson
when he was a postdoc with nathan indeed
where he essentially builds a shallow
decoder network
so that you can take this low resolution
down single engine panel b
you can reconstruct from training data
the high resolution
flow field that you use to trade
so this is the super resolution and this
is again positive turbulent
data set so this works
surprisingly well with relatively small
data set when you set it up as an
interpolation task
and i really want to highlight that in
machine learning
the neural network approaches that a lot
of people are using and that we're using
here
are extremely powerful for interpolation
but they're not that great for
extrapolation
so if you look at the lower left here
what you'll see is
how we have arranged our training and
our test data
so the train data is given by these dark
columns in gray and the test data are
these light
blue columns so what you'll notice is
that nearly every
test data set is sandwiched between two
training set and so in some sense
everything is interpolated
in the future but when you set up the
problem to look more like an
extrapolation task
so i train on the first 70 of my data
and then i
test on the next 30 in time
the prediction starts off being very
good you get very good super resolution
for short times
but for longer times the super
resolution degrades quite rapidly
and again this is just pointing out the
fact that interpolation problems are
somehow easy
and extrapolation problems can be quite
difficult
okay now in image sciences
google images or facebook you often have
um kind of this idea
that these tasks can really be doing
extrapolation
but i would argue that google images and
facebook
have so many images their training data
is so large
that almost every task in the future is
fundamentally an interpolation between
things you've already seen in the past
okay and so for us to reach that level
of data
in fluid mechanics so that future tasks
are look like interpolations
is going to be extremely challenging for
highly uh turbulent flows
even right looking climate science or
control
we want to train on the past we don't
believe that the future is going to
necessarily look like the past either in
the climate because
role because we're actively trying to
boom
okay so this is kind of a caveat that's
where you're wrapped into one you can
get
lots of great results with interpolation
but extrapolation is hard
okay good i'm gonna start transitioning
from this idea that you put your data
like images things are easy
and i'm going to start going into this
world of modeling dynamical systems and
bringing in more physics
into the picture okay so that's where
it's really getting interesting uh
at least for my group so i want to talk
about this really exciting work by jared
callahan
a phd student working with me and nathan
where he's essentially trying to learn
from data
these dominant balance physics laws that
uh essentially codify asymptotized
balance laws in governing physics
okay so we're going to look at the johns
hopkins
turbulent termula boundary layer data
and i'm going to walk you through how
jared's automated method works
see the reynolds average navier-stokes
equations for that turbulence
that turbulent flow field and you can
see that there are six
equations six terms in the equations so
for each term
i can plot that term spatially over the
entire spatial field
so this is the u var u bar x field
got all six of your equations
like stuff in the bar sometimes they're
small and they
it's in different ways in different
regions of the space
and so what jared realized is that you
can take this data
and you can plot it instead of spatially
equation
firms you can take each space
and you can plot it in a six digital
push space
so every point can be scatter plotted in
the six dimensional equation space
i'm showing you a couple of slices here
in the upper right
and you can see that the data has
patterns there are different patterns
that the data adheres to
in equation space so if we apply
clustering
really simple stuff gaussian mixture
models in this case you can find
that there are these different unique
clusters of these facial points
in how the equation turns
and for example you see in red our w bar
x term is
in the other equation terms and so if we
try to find
spark spaces in an equation of different
cultures live
what you find is that there are these uh
five color-coded regions where you have
different
dominant balance physics where different
terms are
out and balance each other in the
physics
of those really equal to zero so this is
really a data-driven automatic uh
generalization
of the asymptotics from the 50s and the
60s where a lot of applied math
departments and
built around asymptotics dominant
balance for fluids
so these regions and back in space
you find that you recover many of the
kind of the boundary layer
that would be not or hard fought through
uh real analysis
and so for example this all came
directly out of that data just by
plotting it in equation space
we learned from the data that there's a
viscous sub layer and a transitional
region and an inertial sub layer
and those have the right balance physics
uh of which terms are active in those
equations
so in principle you could use this for
reduced order modeling potentially for
different closure modeling in these
different regions
i think the sky's the limit very
expensive
and what's really nice about this is
that you can apply this to systems where
we have not had thousands of brilliant
researchers over 100 years
studying the system so we can apply this
to
optical pulse propagation this is the
super continuum high energy laser
where we can find dominant physics
regimes you can apply this to the gulf
of mexico and recover
geostrophic balances and other balances
and maybe discover
new balances that were slightly more
complicated than what people could write
down with their kind of human intuition
we've applied this to neuroscience
systems rotating detonation engines
i really encourage you to try to think
of an equation
because it is how
okay wonderful so that was just one
kind of approach still based on looking
at things like images
but now we're starting to build in these
dynamical systems elements of the actual
terms of the physics
okay so for the remainder of the talk
for the next half
i'm going to talk almost about reduced
order modeling for
pollutants of interpretable and
generalizable machine learning
good so i have been
preaching this for a while and i know my
good colleague and friend nathan cuts
is also preaching the same story that we
don't just want
black box machine learning techniques
those are powerful
they're useful you know the
representational power of them
cannot be discarded or underestimated
but we don't want all of our advances in
machine learning
okay we want interpretable generalizable
models too
and instead of defining edge
interpretable in general because i'm
sure that i will make most of you trying
to define them
i'm going to describe what i mean
through an analogy so i think that
newton's second law
is the quintessential interpretable
generalizable model
so let's break it down it's
interpretable in
their terms f and
balance each other out we can write
these down for a system
and we can discuss what it means we can
do analysis they're interpretable
it's generalizable in the sense that
newton can learn at equals end date
in the apple on earth or syllabus
and that law is still valid when we
design
space missions to send humans to the
moon so
ultimate generalizable model building
some videos that was only not hurt
with enough data faithfully reproduce
the trajectories of apples and be able
to even make movies of apples falling
but it would pull from designing things
to the moon it would not generalize
beyond fault
and this idea is not just a special
second law
it's special to equal square and in fact
the entire history of mathematics
over the years has been formulated
obsession
that things should be as simple as
possible and no simpler
so this is the principle of parsimony
this is uh
aristotle's principle this was tommy's
principle
pareto uh akka einstein newton
you name it the great advances occurred
because of parsimonious model
and so what that means mathematically
today
in my opinion is sparsity and low
dimensionality
i want low dimensional models i want to
get rid of all of the clutter
and focus on the variables that matter
what are the variables that matter for
the following
well it's f m and a now
sparsity comes in because the
description the physical
law that describes how those low
dimensional quantities interact
i want it as possible too i wanted to
have as few terms as possible
and generally i'm
sorry interrupt um i don't know why but
um the sound is breaking sometimes so
maybe you can um uh
not showing your face the video the
video and just
can you hear me better now um yeah
yeah let's try that yeah let's try that
yeah let's try that good so so the real
idea here
is that by imposing sparsity and low
dimensionality
we tend to promote models that are
robust interpretable
and generalizable and so that's what i'm
going to talk about
um for the second half of the talk now
newton's second law
is great but for complex systems like
fluid flows
i think an even better analogy is this
thermal convection model
of lorentz the lorent63 model
so the idea here is that even for a very
complicated high dimensional fluid flow
like rayleigh bernard convection
if we pull out the right coordinate
system you can get a very very simple
model for this fluid flow given by these
lorentz equations
uh here in x y and z
and again this has all of the three
characteristic the two characteristics
we're looking for
it's low dimensional in terms of three
variables x y and z
and the right hand side dynamics are
sparse only a few
terms are active in the dynamics out of
all the things that you could possibly
write down to describe those equations
and so this is the kind of idea we want
to bring into fluids we want to automate
lorentz
or fluid systems and the way that we do
that is through this algorithm called
the sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics or
cindy for an acronym and i'm going to
walk you through this on the lorette
system
so we're going to imagine that we have
the system on the left
but we don't know the equation all that
we do is measure
x y and z and we compute the derivatives
x dot y dot and z dot from those
measurements
so each row is a measurement in time
and the simplest thing you might be able
to do is a linear best fit regression
that's what the dynamic mode
decomposition does
is a linear best fit regression to find
the best
three by three a matrix that would map x
y and z
to x dot y dot z dot but i don't think
any of us really believe
that a three by three linear model could
possibly capture
the richness and complexity of the
lorette system the a matrix has one
fixed point at the origin
whereas lorentz has multiple fixed
points and unstable periodic orbits
and chaos and so instead of this linear
regression
what we do is we augment our right hand
side library
to include more possible terms in the
library in the dynamics
and now the goal is to find the fewest
columns of theta
that equal x dot to equal y dot and then
equal
z dot in this case my theta matrix
includes polynomials up to fifth order
polynomials
and those can all be constructed from my
measurements of x y and z
now if you asked me 20 years ago i would
have said that this is actually
an intractable brute force problem you
wouldn't be able to solve the sparse
optimization
but in the last 20 years this has
essentially become a commodity there are
dozens of algorithms for finding the
sparsest linear combination
of columns of theta that equal x dot and
in doing so
what we find is that the sparses
combination of
terms that equal x dot are actually the
terms in the original
red system and the same for y dot and z
dot
and so by collecting the data like this
and applying sparse optimization
we essentially uncover the nonlinear
structure
and the parameters of our of our lorette
system that generated that data
and remember in this example i never saw
the equations i
only collected measurement data so this
is true nonlinear system identification
you can actually uncover
real physics from measurement data
now if you're interested in this we
recently released an open source
software package pi
cindy so you can download this and try
it out yourself
on your data sets
good so now you can also instead of just
discovering ordinary differential
equations we can discover partial
differential equations
let's say i take my flow path to
cylinder example
where i measure omega the vorticity and
the
x and y components of velocity u and v
now i can build a similar library like
in cindy
but i can include partial derivatives of
these variables and nonlinear products
of those partial derivatives
and when i find the sparsest combination
that equals the time derivative of
vorticity
lo and behold we find we uncover
the non the navier-stokes equations and
we get the reynolds number to within
about one percent
which is quite remarkable since our data
is so
vast in space and time you can
dramatically
down sample your data and when you run
this library
uh regression on even on this sub sample
data we still
recover the correct equations so pretty
cool we've applied this to
you know a dozen other pdes and in every
case where we knew the answer ahead of
time
our method came up with the true physics
of the system
and we're currently using this with our
collaborators
in plasma physics to try to find
a hierarchy of models that goes beyond
the mhd equations that are both more
complex
and less complex at different fidelities
okay so now i'm going to talk about how
we use these to get reduced order models
for fluids
so back to our flow path to cylinder in
noak and collaborators in this famous
paper
showed us that if we measure the system
in the right coordinate frame
in these three coordinates given by pod1
pod2
and the shift mode then our system
actually becomes quite simple we can
alert and project the navier-stokes
equations
onto these three modes and we get a
system of ordinary differential
equations in blue here
that is characterized by a slow manifold
a parabolical manifold
that captures all of the transient and
steady state behavior of the system
so we thought this would be a good test
case for cindy
we collect measurements of the
simulation in those coordinates
and we run it through our sparse library
procedure
and what we find is a governing equation
system
this is very similar to that in blue we
have the same slow quadratic manifold
the same transient and so this is very
promising we can discover the reduced
order model
that experts you know took years to
write down
no act and all directly from the
measurement data if we measure it in the
right coordinates
x y and z now shortly after
we published this paper i got an email
from john kristoff lazo from paris tech
and he came up with two very very
cool innovations that i think have made
this much more powerful for physical
systems
so the first innovation is that
we know a tremendous amount about the
structure of the navy or stokes equation
and how those conservation of energy
manifests itself in these reduced order
equations
specifically we know that these models
have skew-symmetric quadratic
non-linearities
and so our sparsity procedure
is essentially based on an iterative
least squares
procedure where you do a least square
solution you
zero out small terms of the coefficients
you do another least squares onto the
remaining coefficients
you zero out the small ones and so on
and so forth
and at each stage we can include
constraint equations that enforce the
skew symmetric
symmetric energy conservation and so
what jc did was just by adding these
constraint equations
you can force our cindy models to be
conservative by construction
which immediately improves stability of
the models
the second innovation that i think is
really neat is
our original model we tried to include
quadratic
non-linearities because that's what the
navy or stokes equations have
but if you allow yourself higher order
non-linearities cubic
quintet septic nautic terms you can
account for the
very low energy mode that we've
truncated
on how they affect the the high energy
modes x and y
and so just as a cartoon here what you
see in this z
equation if lambda is a very fast
eigenvalue
then z rapidly equilibrates to x squared
plus y squared
that's what this slow parabolic manifold
means
and if you substitute z equals x squared
plus y squared into the first two
equations
you get a term that looks cubic uh
that third term looks cubic and
similarly
if i substitute in the next higher
frequency mode pair
i'll get fifth order terms and the next
higher mode pair
are seventh order and so on and so forth
and by
including these higher order
non-linearities we in some sense get a
rudimentary closure model
for the low energy modes we've truncated
good
now let's see how well this works on
some real examples so the cavity flow
and the cylinder flow here
the column on the right what i'm showing
is
the industry standard state-of-the-art
pod galerkin models
with three modes and seven modes
so the white curve here is a proxy for
the drag coefficient
and you can see how it evolves in time
now both of the pod
models essentially capture the right
qualitative dynamics but they fail
quantitatively
they have the wrong rise time they
overshoot and they have steady state
error
but when we include these cubic
constrained cindy models
we almost perfectly quantitatively match
all of the aspects of this transient
drag coefficient
so this is much more accurate and useful
for drag prediction and for control
and what's nice is that these cindy
models are sparse by construction they
only have a few terms
and so we can manipulate those terms and
this is exactly what jc
did and he was able to cook up an
extremely simple model
in terms of the cylinder flow as a
spring mass damper with nonlinear
damping or a van der pol oscillator
and so to date uh to my knowledge this
is both the most
accurate and the simplest model for the
cylinder flow that has ever been written
down
okay and so that's what i mean when i
say that sparse
low dimensional modeling gives you the
power of really extracting something
interpretable
and generalizable now you don't need the
full flow field to do this you don't
need to do pod
it turns out you can build these models
purely based on lift and drag
measurements on the bodies themselves
so in this case the fluidic pinball we
have three cylinders in an arrangement
and all we measure is lift and drag and
you can build very very faithful
nonlinear models to capture these lift
and drag dynamics
okay good so um let's go back to this
chaotic thermal convection so i've shown
you hopefully
that we can get reduced order models for
these these wake systems and
shear systems um and going back to this
lorentz model for a thermal convection i
really want to share
this uh cool work by jc this is the same
jc lonzo from before
this is where he published in 2020 just
at the end of last year
where he's looking at this thermal this
thermosyphon which is basically a hula
hoop
that is heated from below and cools from
the top
and by extracting the modes using
dynamic mode decomposition
and modeling the time series using cindy
he showed that this system has exactly
the same
dynamics as the traditional lorenz 63
model
of standard rayleigh bernard convection
which is very cool
so he showed in some sense that this
lorentz model is a normal form for other
types of
thermal convection in different
geometries
i've recently worked with igor novosilov
and ife quan who is his phd student
on chaotic electro convection which has
a more complex
three-way coupling between the fluid
flow the charge density and the electric
field
and what we found is that this is an
incredibly rich chaotic conduction
system
so if you take your time series of data
and you extract your low dimensional
representation your pod modes
what we find is that the mode amplitudes
how these mode
amplitudes evolved in time have
incredible symmetries
so a1 is the amplitude of mode 1 a2 is
the amplitude of mode 2 and so on and so
forth
and these mode mixtures change in time
but they adhere to these very strong
symmetries that you see in the data
and so we can extract what symmetries
had to be true from the data
and enforce those in our constraints in
the architecture
and what we get out is a sparse kind of
skeletal model
that captures those qualitative features
uh of
this kind of symmetric chaotic
convection system
and i want to zoom in a little farther
to these symmetries so if we zoom in
to this data we find these five
fundamental symmetries
and what that means is that when i build
my cindy library all of these different
nonlinear terms
many of them more than half of them are
immediately eliminated
because they can't possibly exist with
those observed symmetries
and so what this does is this means that
we're searching in a much
smaller search space of possible
nonlinear
dynamics and so we can get away with
less data we get better models with less
data by enforcing these symmetries
and our resulting model essentially
captures these different chaotic paths
that the system can take very faithfully
it captures the statistics
and we can reconstruct the flows uh
dynamically
using these models so i was pretty
pleased with this i was really
impressed uh by this work by ebay guan
who's now a postdoc at rice
uh and alan captain auglu who's a
fantastic phd student working with me
has been extending this to spheromach
fusion reactors
so he has a simulation here that's
matched to
an experiment and by extracting the
right pod mode these are dimensional pnd
modes
he's able to build these sparse
constrained cindy models
that essentially captured the same
attracting dynamics of these course
variables
much much more efficient than actually
solving these numerically
so we're hoping that we can include the
effects of control
and disturbances and injector dynamics
and actually use these
reduced order models for efficient
real-time control
in experiments good
okay so the last thing i'm going to tell
you about before i break for questions
is how we are extending this to
stochastic systems
so this is work by jared callahan that
he calls longivin regression
and the idea here is that for really
turbulent systems
we're not just modeling a few coherent
structures there's also this effect of
turbulence and forcing
so we're not only going to model x not
equals f of x
where x are my low dimensional coherent
structures
we're also going to include this effect
of colored
noise forcing in sigma x that accounts
for all of the turbulence
this is called the launch of an equation
and we're going to identify this using
our cindy approach
now this is closely related to or
plump which involves
distributions and i'm not going to go
through all of the details of our
algorithm
essentially we're parameterizing our
nonlinear dynamics and our noise model
and we're trying to learn a sparse
nonlinear model from the system
this requires building distributions and
doing adjoint optimization so it's a bit
more involved
but in every example we've looked at
from toy problems
to turbulent wakes we uncover
low dimensional nonlinear dynamical
systems models with the correct
bifurcation
and with the correct colored noise
forcing and we've applied this to
experiments with our collaborator george
regis and imperial
for the turbulent axis symmetric wake of
a bluff body
with real turbulent experimental data
and it works
and so just for a movie here and this is
again that's
um a more turbulent cavity flow example
and what we find is that we don't just
get the right uh
kind of quasi-periodic behavior we also
get the right broadening
of that trajectory because of the noise
model because of this colored noise
model
so that's also really important for uh
turbulent statistics
okay so i've talked about a lot and i
think it's probably best at this point
for me to stop
and field any questions and i have tons
of
additional stuff i'd love to talk about
so feel free to ask me anything
thank you so much thank you so much
what a great talk as usual um
let's yeah let's open uh to the audience
for the
any any questions please
speak out if you have any questions
okay i have one um so a lot of videos to
the model
you know the one of the goal of the
video model is
getting good accurate you know
solutions but at the same time you would
like to accelerate
and get some speed up compared to the
corresponding high fidelity models we
have
so i haven't seen any speed up
results from your presentation so if you
can comment on
some of them
stephen i i cannot hear you um i'm sorry
i needed myself and then i forgot
so yeah that's a great question thank
you um a lot of what i'm showing here
fits very much into the framework of
reduced order modeling that people use
with
projection-based methods galarkin
projection
um you know they have these known speed
ups over
uh over full yes
and so i'm not supposed to talk about
the factors but i would argue that our
methods are actually
um better
in terms of speed up than galore
projection
because if i take an n dimensional pde
discretization
and i project it on to r mode let's say
r
is a hundred my quadratic non-linearity
is going to end up looking like an r by
r
by r tensor so r cubed
okay and so very quickly even
for moderate reduced order uh dimensions
our reduced order models can become as
expensive as the original
order model but our models are not
dense like those reduced order galerkin
projection models
in galerkin projection every single term
that could be there
is there whereas our sparse procedure
kills as many terms as possible
so our scaling the number of terms that
we get is much closer to r
log r which is much much better than r
cubed
so again none of this is rigorous but in
principle
well these are extremely extremely fast
fast enough
for for instance that you could use them
for real-time model predictive control
in some examples very nice very nice
thank you for the answer
steve we have a bunch of questions but
uh trains you raise your hand
so i did okay
yeah go ahead hey save nice talk very
nice thought
as usual i have a i have a quick
question for you so
um i mean is there so you you mentioned
this
projection reducer the models um and
and since they they're derived from you
know like pdes with uh
with classical tools like alerting
projections so so
many times it's easy to straightforward
to prove uh
to prove uh you know things like
convergence like uh
stability for the for the you know uh
for these videos or the models
projection based for example so can you
do the same for
for the for the models that you're uh
you know that cindy spits out
so i understand that you know you and jc
uh came up with this idea of uh
constraining and i think that this
you know uh add some mathematical uh
support to
to these models but other than that is
there anything else that that
you can you can prove yeah that's a
fantastic question
uh and i think you're you're 100 correct
like this is one of the strengths of
traditional approaches is that there is
this wealth of
rules um that they've been really hard
fought to build
these urgent guarantees and uh stability
guarantees for gilligan projection
models for projection models
um and i'm actually very very excited
about this um so alan i mean allen is
just
a incredible researcher and he's working
on one of the hardest problems in my lab
this mhd fusion equation we have
lots of terms in the model high
dimensional
state vectors so he's really challenging
himself with a lot of the complexity
that cindy sometimes struggles with and
so his
models are not always fiction right
oftentimes he'll cook up a model and it
just blows up it's really frustrating
and so instead of getting frustrated
what alan
did was this is very recent um it's not
published yet
he's taken that global convergence
result of
uh yan haas and barrett nowak
and has essentially built in those
global stability and convergence
uh conditions into this in the
optimization procedure
so you can look at it two ways one a
cindy model now we can analyze directly
what is global
sorry what is basis of attraction is
using these conditions
and second of all we can add as a
constraint to our regression that we
want our
you know stability in a certain epsilon
ball
around you know wherever our training
data is still kind of wrapping our heads
around
how useful this is how well it works how
much more expensive
you you know again just figures to sort
this out but
it really blew me away i didn't think it
was possible and so
um if you had asked me a month ago i
would have told you something totally
different so that's how
fast alan's been working on this thanks
for the great question
sure thank you oh yeah actually i'd love
to get your opinion about you know i
know we have quite a few experts
uh here you know uh training among them
so
this we would certainly benefit from uh
from a little bit of a sanity check here
since this is not our
um you know our main mainline research
okay uh let's move on to the next
question then driver
raise uh the hands how why don't you uh
on major assessments because
hi uh less of a question and
maybe more of a request it looks pretty
incredible and i think
it would be really helpful for me if you
hosted something like a hands-on
workshop
maybe like a half a day that was like
data to dynamics with cindy
where we just learn how to turn the
crank and
and things like that i think that would
be really incredible so the less of a
question and just a
thumbs up maybe for for a workshop
thanks that's a great suggestion um you
know
out there in a very distributed sense
you might be bringing it together in a
workshop
um so for example we have um
brian da silva led this pi cindy package
and so he has you know github tools and
youtube tutorials
through the youtube software
kristoff lawso and every second
lectures and he's a brilliant lecturer
and he
you know has built this into his
curriculum for his master's students
so exactly how to kind of build these
models
i think you're right like it would be
nice if we could provide an engaging
kind of interactive community
workshop effort thanks for the
suggestion yeah thank you i
will definitely be pulling i think i'll
definitely be pulling the library
out and um maybe if you could uh send
some of those resources
to youngsu to distribute to this list
that would be really great i'd love to
watch those videos and we can pretend to
be masters students
for a day cool sounds good thank you
that sounds good okay let's move on to
the next uh brian you
raise your hands why don't you amuse
yourself and speak up
hi it was a great talk thank you so much
um i just had a quick question i was
wondering um
you didn't talk much about um how many
simulations uh
were needed to sort of generate the data
that you did this sort of a
decomposition on and
i wanted to get a sense of how many you
know runs you need to do
since since in my field at least there's
you know it's very expensive to run
these folder models so we're not we
wouldn't be able to run them uh
generate that that much data so i just
wanted to get a sentence yeah
that's a fantastic question um it
totally depends
so you know we've been surprised in both
directions before
um and i think you can still see my
powerpoint slide
so uh when we look at this
equation um okay so in the lorettz
equation
kathleen champion showed us something
that absolutely blew us away
if i have data from a half of a period
of this thing it's basically going
around one half of a load
if i have data with a fine enough delta
t
you
so sometimes it can be very very smart
if it's clean and fast um
and so they're already free often noisy
data or use or less data or more
you know there's kind of this cube of
when it works and when it doesn't
for the fluid flow examples if i
remember
i gave the system two or three
trajectories
this took me a couple of hours to
generate on my laptop
and you know i had a trajectory that was
it started at point c
and wound up i had one that started at
point d
and wound down and then wound up and
then i think i had another trajectory i
forget which one
and i had another trajectory that i used
as a test one that was not used for
training
so again for this you know relatively
clean numerical data with a pretty fast
pt
i actually need that much data just two
or three older
trajectories great this was a great
question
okay next uh rap replica
can you omit yourself and ask your
question hi um i had a question about
systems with missing information
for example what would happen with your
models if you
fed in something like the lorenz system
but left out
one of the coordinates like z how would
your system fare
recovering the information or
rediscovering the indian state
so that's a really really really good
question
and it turns out that this was an entire
large research effort that we stumbled
onto by asking that exact same question
so i don't know if you can still see my
am i still sharing my screen
yes yes you are okay i'm going to share
a different screen
okay can you see this keynote now a
different one
okay so we got a fantastic referee
comment in our original cindy paper and
asked that exact question what if i
don't measure
all of my variables i don't measure x y
and z i just measure
x okay and so essentially what we do
is we take that
resolved data measurement or that that
single measurement and we
build a henkel matrix the moment where
our net vector with time delays
we can choose the svd of that matrix so
we get these kind of
angular coordinates and it turns out
that this is very closely related to the
groupman operator
these timeline coordinates give you an
embedding of the coupement operator
and so when you try to build a linear
model on those time delay coordinates
the linear model you get is linear which
is crazy so we do cindy
in the non-linear terms just a sparse
linear model
in a coordinates and this linear
used for very nasty chaotic systems
long story short is that um that
question
was very fortuitous for us and helped us
stumble upon this idea that time delay
coordinates
actually give you a universal account
embedding so
like it opened up a whole can of words
but very interesting stuff
thanks for the great question
okay um i don't see anyone raising
their hands but we have a handful of
questions in chat room so
let's start with a jazz piano
is there a requirement that the dynamic
systems
be elliptical or can hyperbolic systems
also be modeled by
wrong yeah that's a great question so
definitely reduce
order modeling methods for broad ranges
of different classes and pdes
so there's um there's reduced order
models there's reduced basis method
there are you know you name it there's
different classes and methods for these
different classes
and i think in principle almost all the
generalized
kind of modern regression ideas so for
example what i've shown you here is
cindy for
time varying systems we also have a
cindy boundary value problem
so uh even if you have boundary value
problems you know or
like things we can build non-linear
models for those structures
so that's a little bit of a tangential
answer but i would say
it's a bit broader today
okay next question is from dick zhang
he asked can you please explain more
details about the results of complex
high reynolds number problems in your
last slide
i'm asking this because i have
experienced many other data driven
a attempts for reduced modeling before
machine learning
however although many of them worked
almost perfectly
for simple problems such as lawrence
attractor and
von karman vortex shedding behind a
cylinder none of them
were successful for complex confidence
problems thus
it is really great to hear that your
method worked
for by bifurcating problems tolerance
etc
yeah i mean i was blown away when this
worked like
you know again if you asked me a year
ago uh water products for real
turbulence where
i'd say you know it's kind of this works
on laminar problems it's good for flow
control and reduced
modeling but i would be skeptical and
actually it's not just our
team um several researchers from across
the world have
come up with different cindy
perspectives for closure modeling so
there's a great paper out of michigan
and others in german doing this
our perspective is really big on you i'm
going to jump around my slides a little
so please
to get verdict to go um if we go down to
this picture here
you know this will not work for full
unstructured turbulence isotropic box
turbulence i don't think that's going to
work
it's going to work when you have these
elements patterns these kind of low
dimensional coherence
and perturbed and that's
that's what we believe we have in these
experimental systems
so for example um trying to find my
backup slide here
um this is an experiment of a d-shaped
body with our collaborators in germany
and brownshine
and you can see that you know you get
this kind of you still get vortex
force by turbulence or spin stochastic
noise
these kinds of persistence matter now
i because it's very hard for projection
based roms
to capture this turbulence
because it's very rigid and constru
whereas when you
regress you have a little bit more
degrees of freedom it's a little bit
wigglier
so your coefficients can move a little
to be more accommodating to the data
and to things that you're leaving out of
the data
again we're still you know writing this
up we're still trying to figure this out
so i can't give you a
perfectly satisfying answer but we were
surprised too and very pleasantly
surprised
okay let's move on to the next question
question by
jeffrey given that you can capture the
aggregate dynamics of the lorenz system
can you say anything about extending the
time window
of predictability for systems with
strong dependence
of initial conditions for example
weather
yeah that's a great question um so i'll
point out that in the lorette system
we're learning the lorette system like
we're basically learning the lorette
system almost perfectly almost to
machine precision
coefficient of the moment system which
means that our model has exactly the
same
sensitive dependence as the lorenzo we
have the same chaos we have the same
exponential divergence of
trajectory and so the forecasting
problem
well it doesn't seem much better um it's
you know how do i want to say it
at least we have the model that is
actually what is governing the
stretching and folding of trajectories
so that's good we can use that for
better data assimilation
and better for uncertainty
but we still have these fundamental
limitations
and every system is going to have that
if someone tells you that they can beat
uh so i'm gonna i'm gonna like
really interesting results on these uh
reservoir reservoir networks and
reservoir learning for
for forecasting chaos and
i think you know the popular media has
miscommitted authors have
said very carefully the authors said the
right thing very carefully
um quantifying how their error grows in
these predictions
if you look at this cube of initial
conditions in red here
you'll see that it actually stays
coherent it is not doing
exponential stretching until
it gets close to the saddle point at the
bottom so it's still not even stretching
that much
and now when it gets to the saddle point
at the bottom that's when the
exponential stretching
occurs and gets out of control so
in chaos it's not like you always have
exponential strength
there are massively increased
uh the local we have an estimate and the
stretching and so the
results of the machine learning model
predicting the future of
the autism all of them everything
including the true loretz model
is going to begin to fail eventually
when your trajectories go through those
saddle points like that's just
that's the nature of those equations
either they're exact
or approximate
yeah it's a really cool question really
cool research area
and i think by uh
and others on the reservoir computing is
super interesting okay
um it's thank you so much steve uh for
answering the questions we have one last
question
uh but by the way it's past full after
one o'clock
um are you still available dude uh yeah
i can go for a couple more minutes sure
okay awesome okay this is the last
question i see from
um tyrol armand okay these examples show
derivation of complete models from data
as
um have you looked at taking traditional
models and
attempting to check out missing physics
for example looking at the van space cfp
code
and giving it to the fidelity of les or
dns by reduced more order models
collectors implicit in the simpler
formulations
yes i love this question it's an
incredibly good um
so i will say that our colleagues have
absolutely been using this for closure
modeling for modeling missing
uh terms and you know for lds and for
ram modeling
so yes definitely not us per se but our
colleagues
we get to model missing physics in
uh plasma dynamics so if you have a
very very highly resolved kind of
you know particle and cell method
simulations
there the magnesium hydrodynamics the
mhd equations are only approximate
those full dynamics and there are
missing terms that we're trying to
recover
uh with our collaborators at slack and
i'll just find this last slide here
uh we have a pretty big effort uh
working with boeing and others on what
we call discrepancy modeling
where we have an imperfect model
something like a hamiltonian
and we're focusing our modeling effort
on this discrepancy term
the model mismatch and so what we see
here
on the top is it's not really a bad
model it's just our imperfect
model on the bottom this is going to be
correct for that model mismatch
and focus our modeling efforts on on
that discrepancy feature
and it's a good enough model for
stabilizing the inverted pencil
good question thank you thank you so
much steve um i think
that's all the questions i have been i
mean do you do you get any questions
uh directly to you uh people kind of
believe these are the ones that i've
seen as well okay
awesome well uh okay let's thank the
our speaker steve um today for the
wonderful talk
um well as usual thank you so much steve
thank you everyone i really appreciate
it and it was very uh informative
and um straightforward easy to follow
talk we i think we all got to learn
something from
from steve thank you so much for that uh
and
also thank you so much for participating
even though we passed the our due
time which is one o'clock seven minutes
after one o'clock
and this shows how enthusiastic we are
about the data with data-driven physical
simulations so
we will continue our seminar i believe
that our next seminar is
wednesday next week so
please stay tuned and stay healthy
of course and that's how it's gone
okay thanks thank you
you